in case you missed it we're counting
down the days to this year's next 2023
and I'll be sharing some first looks at
duet AI in Google Cloud earlier this
year at Google I O we announced duet AI
an entire system of tools to help
developers build applications in the
cloud so let's take a look at some sneak
peeks of new features we'll be talking
more about at next
today we're taking a look at recitation
checking in our last sneak peek we
shared how duet AI is able to generate
Big Blocks of code and with recitation
tracking you'll be able to easily check
where the code came from so you can
provide license attribution but you'll
have to tune into next to learn more in
the meantime check out the link in our
description to sign up to join Google
Cloud's AI trusted tester program it's
where people can learn about experience
and give feedback on Google Cloud's
emerging AI Technologies want more sneak
peeks keep an eye on this channel as we
count down the days to next